Now, one other thing affects pricing, and we should think about it.
If you remember our discussion about market type,
we have existing markets, we resegment markets, we might be in a new market,
or in a country outside the United States we might cloning an existing business model.
But if we're in an existing market,
we've got to think about competition.
Is there a monopoly?
Is there a duopoly? An oligopoly?
That is, are there dominant players that really shape the pricing in our markets?
What we really want to understand is what's their product?
What are their costs and prices?
And what pricing will make them feel the worst?
More importantly, can we do strategies like bracket them?
Can we undercut them? Can we niche or blue ocean strategy them?
These are the things you want to think about.
If there are dominant players in an existing market,
you want to actually have pricing as a strategy,
not just a reaction.